his lawyer says if the courts approved
this way of gathering evidence police
could use all kinds of trickery to enter
private places
pretend you're a federal agent and
you're pretty sure some high rollers in
a Vegas hotel suite are involved in some
real bad stuff like illegal sports
betting bad at not sports if people are
freakin bags you're low on evidence but
high on moxie what would you do faced
with that scenario FBI agents in Las
Vegas got creative they showed up at the
door of a Caesars Palace suite posing as
computer repairmen offering laptops to
the wealthy guests inside those Ledger's
working when that didn't work FBI agents
cut the internet to this suite then
returned to the room pretending to be
internet repairman Cable Guy
I'll take a look at the router that's
probably the problem once inside they
snuck around and gathered evidence which
they used to get a warrant hey Lou
remind me to try that one
the agents then headed back to the suite
and arrested Paul fois and seven others
for allegedly running an illegal
gambling operation not how you do police
work results woz attorney says when
agents asked a federal magistrate judge
for the warrant they carefully omitted
the shenanigans they pulled to get the
evident Eisley done sir
nicely done and a cover-up is one thing
but there's something else here this
could be a test case that determines how
much trickery law enforcement can use to
enter any home the danger here is that
agents will cut off not only the
internet but your electricity your phone
your cable television come on dope
federal agents have better things to do
well the FBI's most-wanted list includes
men wanted for kidnapping rape and
murder so instead of playing Cable Guy
scamming your way into a hotel room and
then allegedly covering it up in order
to fight sports betting how about
spending more time busting kidnappers
rapists and murderers they all would
have done the whole stripper-gram thing
oh I'll get in that way follow the show
on Twitter submit your nominees for next
month and check out Holly Keller this
month's featured follower
are you filming me